septembre 2009
mobilisation générale à gauche contre le
projet de loi sur la poste syndicats des
partis politiques décident
l'organisation d'un référendum citoyen
leur cible
le changement de statut de la poste
au 1er janvier 2011 les postes
européennes doivent s'ouvrir totalement
à la concurrence en france le
gouvernement en profite pour transformer
d'établissements publics la poste en
société anonyme
une provocation pour l'opposition qui y
voit le premier acte d'une privatisation
et la dégradation annoncée du service
public
c'est au sénat qu'il revient examiné en
premier la réforme postale
pierre hérisson et le rapporteur du
texte c'est un spécialiste de ces
questions
il est sur la même ligne que le
gouvernement en ce qui concerne le
changement de statut
donc nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
le havre en cette fin septembre 2009 il
entame une série d'auditions pour
préparer son rapport aux syndicats élus
experts cadres dirigeants de la poste
tour à tour différents groupes
d'intérêts vont venir exposer leur
vision de la réforme pour certains et je
suis de ceux-là
la poste devrait être en forme et blanc
de la loire en société anonyme à
majorité publique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut écrire un peu comme
les statuts l'entreprise presque bien un
statut aux talents comiques et je dirais
même exclusivement fuite
d'expérience les salariés sa couverture
du capitole est toujours synonyme de
privatisation de recherche de
rentabilité financière au détriment du
service public et les personnels qu'ils
soient pour ou contre la société anonyme
le changement de statut est au coeur des
débats et certains sénateurs vont monter
au créneau michel teston un spécialiste
des questions postale fin technicien il
est le chef de file des socialistes sur
le texte fournit un conte store vous
l'avez dit aucune directive européenne
aucune législation cadre puisque c'est
aujourd'hui soit la formule qu'il faut
employer n'impose un changement de
statut de la poste française martial
bourquin élu socialiste du doubs il suit
de très près le sujet dans son
département
moi je pense qu'une recapitalisation
était nécessaire de la poste doit se
moderniser mais en même temps pourquoi
pas c'est faire ce passage obligé vers
la société anonyme pour soi-disant se
moderniser les sénateurs de gauche
craignent une dégradation des missions
de service public de la poste
les cadres dirigeants de l'entreprise
vont donc tenter de les rassurer
pluzz dans notre esprit le changement de
forme juridique ne change absolument
rien à l'exercice de ces missions nous
avions ces missions ont été qualifiés
par la loi en 2005 et en 2008 en tant
qu'établissement public
nous gardons dans l'ensemble de ces
missions bien sûr en tant que société
anonyme le moment venu un message qui ne
convainc pas à gauche tout comme une
partie de l'opinion
côté rue justement le référendum citoyen
bat son plein il ya une feuille
d'émargement ou les personnes mettent
leur nom leur résidence et signe et
après il leur reste à choisir un choix ô
combien cornélien entre le changement de
statut et la climatisation ou au
contraire rester dans le secteur public
et répondre aux besoins des populations
l'objectif du comité arriver à un
million de votants pour faire pression
sur le gouvernement et provoquer un vrai
référendum sur le changement de statut
de la poste
on nous a fait le coup des chats pour
france télécom on nous a fait le coup
pour aider m et surtout pour gdf ou
l'état à changer la loi dans une seule
année et aujourd'hui on sait très bien
que ce changement de statut
c'est vraiment faire sauter un verrou le
verrou de l'entreprise publique pour
demain faire entrer des investisseurs
privés hiriart des limites à
l'hypocrisie et au mensonge
les opposants la société anonyme ne
crois pas au maintien d'un capital 100%
public
ils craignent qu'à terme l'état se
retire du capital comme pour gdf
il n'y aura pas de privatisation d'edf
et de gaz de france ni aujourd'hui ni
demain
pour une raison simple c'est que
l'intention déterminée du gouvernement
de la france c'est que l'état car de la
majorité du capital de cette grande
entreprise
aujourd'hui l'état ne détient plus que
35% de gdf suez
l'argument sert donc au comité national
pour mobiliser les français sur la
question de la poste devant la poste de
château rouge le plus célèbre poster de
france dans l'oise ils sont plus de
15000 à s'être prononcé et un peu plus
de 3500 dans l'aisne en charente
maritime
25000 opinions exprimées un véritable
plébiscite est un bon coup médiatique en
quelques jours la votation citoyenne a
pris une ampleur inattendue
aujourd'hui pour moi il ya vraiment un
succès sur cette opération on est à
presque 3500 points de vote le million
évidemment c'est un chiffre qui est
énorme il faut bien considérer que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai jamais vu
personnellement comment on est tous
d'accord dans tous deux comités que
cette initiative est complètement
original bon après c'est quand même un
rapport de force un peu différent il ya
quand même un vrai signal qui a envoyé
au gouvernement
nicolas galepidès est un des acteurs
principaux du mouvement administrateur
de la poste il connaît parfaitement les
rouages de l'établissement public
retour au sénat où les auditions se
poursuivent et où la votation citoyenne
inquiète peu le rapporteur volé chez les
citoyens à s'exprimer sur le sujet ceci
étant la question qui est posée ne
correspond pas à la réalité du texte de
loi qu'il s'agit d'un autre texte de loi
mais en tout cas non à la privatisation
de la poste je pense que on est tous on
peut tous signé cette pétition n'est pas
le problème
moi le premier moi je peux signer une
pétition qui dit non et réserver la
poste précisément puisque nous allons
essayer d'écrire dans la loi du mieux
possible
mieux possible l'impossibilité d'un
qu'un jour les choses se passent de
cette manière mais pour pirelli sont de
la société anonyme est la seule solution
pour recapitaliser la poste
déjà très endetté il s'agit tout
simplement de fabrique et on va faire
simple de fabriquer la boîte qui
permettra de recevoir les deux milliards
sept en apporte définitif qui fera
partie du capital social intégrale de la
poste et qui lui permettra de poursuivre
son développement de poursuivre sa
modernisation
au delà des 6 milliards d'euros qu'elle
a déjà emprunté et pour lequel ne peut
pas aller plus loin puisqu'elle n'a pas
la capacité de rembourser plus
d'annuités qu'elle rembourse aujourd'hui
2 milliards 700 millions d'euros le
tiers de la valeur de la poste l'état
versera directement 1,2 milliard le
reste c'est cet homme qui va les
apporter
augustin de romanet le patron de la
caisse des dépôts le bras financier de
l'état la caisse détiendra donc une part
importante du capital de la poste michel
teston veut s'assurer qu'il s'agit d'un
investissement à long terme
une inquiétude forte par rapport à
l'injure et de votre participation je ne
mets pas en cause
responsable de la cuisine et
consignations c'est pas un problème que
je pose c'est la question par rapport à
un contexte mondial qui peut être
différent de la pérennité de la
participation de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations quand on est combien navix
long terme ça n'est pas pour sa musique
l'un de mes cadeaux et vendent bien pour
acheter paul je ne prends pas
d'engagement sur cette cette évolution
ne voudra jamais parce que je pense que
si on est capable de bien j'aime poste
elle sera naturellement rentable et
ensuite que son capital soit public
privé en bourse par ces états là je vous
donne mon opinion personnelle on opine
personnel ça ne change rien à la qualité
du service rendu
dès lors que le législateur de me
remettre à tout moment les missions de
service public
les de la foire grâce à la caisse des
dépôts et à l'état 2,7 milliards vont
donc être versée à la poste une somme
censée l'aider à conquérir le marché
européen et réinventer ses métiers
à
dans chaque village comme un buteur
c'est un personnage qu'on porte dans son
coeur
recevoir une lettre la poste c'est 300
milles postiers ses dix sept mille
points de présence répartis sur tout le
territoire
le premier employeur du pays après
l'état un service public vieux de
plusieurs siècles synonyme de patrimoine
national bref un symbole mais un symbole
en péril et la combattent
photo la route avons mal et brett orion
et aux douces n'ont pas y rester
derrière un guichet si t'es pas capable
de piloter la caisse avec un peu du
courrier irait de plus en plus avec des
caisses comme ça qu'on tient les délais
aujourd'hui le courrier il y en a de
moins en moins internet oblige depuis
2002 les volumes de courrier ne cesse de
baisser -1 6% en 2009 un record la poste
doit vite réduire ses coûts et trouver
de nouvelles sources de revenus mais la
poste n'est pas une entreprise comme une
autre
elle doit remplir des missions de
service public chaque année la poste
achemine plus de 10 milliards de lettres
et plus de 300 millions de paquets par
train avion et toutes sortes de
véhicules qui sillonnent la france
principale mission le service universel
du courrier relevé et distribué six
jours sur sept
jusqu'aux habitations les plus reculées
autre mission de l'aménagement du
territoire dans certains villages
elle est souvent le dernier service
public la dernière activité
dix huit mille bureaux de poste sont à
votre disposition sans vous dire en
respect sciemment fait vos opérations
d'epargne quand vous vous rendez à votre
bureau de poste la poste c'est aussi une
banque elle a l'obligation d'ouvrir un
compte à quiconque en fait la demande
c'est l'accessibilité bancaire
des missions qui ne sont pas remises en
cause directement par le projet de loi
mais pour lesquelles l'ouverture totale
du marché va changer la donne à la
campagne confiez vos opérations d'
épargne aux facteurs vous faites
confiance aux ptt fait confiance à la
caisse nationale d par l'aménagement du
territoire la poste y contribue par son
réseau de points de contact un peu plus
de 17000 qu'ils étaient tous à l'origine
des bureaux de poste classique mais
depuis 2002 la poste a trouvé des
partenaires comme des mairies ou des
commerçants pour alléger sa charge
c'est ce qu'a voulu nous montrer martial
bourquin dans son département
l'endroit ressemble à un bureau de poste
mais nous sommes dans une mairie il
s'agit d'une agence postale communale
la personne derrière le guichet n'est
pas une postière certaines opérations
lui sont interdites pour des raisons de
confidentialité ne pas donner plus de
300 euros par semaine
si lille et lé pour un couple 600 euros
par semaine ce qui change entre un
bureau de poste et une agence postale
communale
c'est surtout au niveau des activités
bancaires au niveau des coui en ce qui
concerne le courrier aux poteaux faire
la poste vers ce 800 euros par mois à la
mairie pour 15 heures d'ouverture
hebdomadaire
cela lui coûte beaucoup moins cher qu'un
bureau classique la mairie de dallas
quelques kilomètres de là n'a pas encore
accepté le partenariat
aucun accord n'a pour l'instant été
trouvé bonjour mais la poste a déjà
anticipé en réduisant les horaires
d'ouverture du bureau
c'est un problème les ouvertures du
bureau de poste
c'est un problème quand il ya tous les
anciens qui viennent qui veulent de
l'argent ils font comment ils peuvent
pas se déplacer puis bon c'est pas 4
pour marcher le bouquin la réduction des
horaires est un moyen de pression pour
la poste belge amplitude horaire c'est
inévitablement dévitalisation du bureau
de poste et c'est ce qui a recherché sa
transformation je pense même qu'une
stratégie de transformation faire en
sorte que la mairie prenne les services
de la poste pour une subvention et dans
certains endroits faut peut-être le
faire dans d'autres non et si nadal
c'est pas le cas parce que il ya des
clients
et il y en avait plus quand c'était plus
ouvert
en quelques années les partenariats se
sont multipliées les bureaux de poste
classique ne sont plus que dix mille
cinq cents sur un total de dix sept
mille points de contact les autres sont
soit des agences en mairie soient des
relais poste chez des commerçants avec à
chaque fois un service réduit la poste
réalise ainsi d'énormes économies car un
partenariat du coûte 5 à 10 fois moins
qu'un bureau classique elle remplit
ainsi sa mission d'aménagement du
territoire à moindre frais mais malgré
ces économies la présence postale coûte
cher 300 millions d'euros selon la poste
un coup que l'état s'engage normalement
à compenser intégralement
or l'allègement de taxe professionnelle
dont elle bénéficie sens et le couvrir
n'a jusqu'à présent jamais été suffisant
au nautic de la poste a accumulé une
dette on ne dit pas que l'état ne paye
pas ce qu'il doit tous les ans à la
poste et on calculait si l'état met à
peu près vers sais ce qu'ils te met la
poste y compris le plan de modernisation
pour être payés parce que doit l'état
elle marque l merci pour le café la
démonstration est simple pour
l'opposition si l'état avait respecté
ses engagements
la poste n'aurait aujourd'hui pas besoin
de trouver 2,7 milliards d'euros
retour au sénat avec l'audition de
l'association des maires de france
particulièrement mobilisé sur le sujet
élus de gauche comme de droite veulent
la garantie que la poste sera à l'avenir
correctement dédommager de sa mission
d'aménagement du territoire et que le
fonds prévus à cet effet soient
correctement financée par l'état il faut
absolument que ce fonds la pénalité d'un
père innovation financière du fonds sont
organisées au que les agences postales
communales qui sont financés par ce
fonds puisse effectivement une garantie
de financement que pierre hérisson est
prêt à inscrire dans la loi sur la
partie aménagement du territoire et sur
la pérennisation peut dire comme ça les
gars de trouver le financement pérenne
sur l'aménagement du territoire le
service public je sais pas comment il va
falloir écrire ça mais il va falloir
l'écrire ça c'est peu près les maires
veulent aussi des garanties sur le
maintien du réseau actuel de la poste
bonjour quelque chose soit fait pour les
inquiétudes des mères soit vous calmez
vous avez peut être intéressant que dans
la loire on affiche le chiffre dix sept
mille points côte à côte
bien sûr que ça peut être une bonne idée
que de l'indiquer dans la loi mais comme
certains d'entre eux viennent de le dire
cela n'empêchera pas la poste
progressivement ne transférerait des
mureaux de plein exercice en agence
postale communale des agences postales
communales en point de contact chez les
commerçants comment on fait pour
empêcher la lecture pour qu'un jour la
france 30 ans couverte des genres
postale communale lèvres l'epo chez les
commerçants
donc faut qu'on arrive à fixer
devenir dans la loi un bureau de poste
c'est quoi et à partir de quel moment où
dans quelles conditions s'est plaint
c'est plus un veau repose de plein
exercice se trouve acculé les
informations chiffrées sont un peu
inquiétantes
actuellement sur les dix minutes sur les
dix sept mille points de contact il y à
6500 partenariat leur esprit l'on dit
1000 et 1500 bureaux de poste au mois
j'ai entendu je prends le volant au
cours d'une réunion de l'observatoire
que si on si la poste
l'entreprise ne regardait que ces
chiffres de rentabilité
anthony mer le nombre de bureaux de
poste redescendre un embryon s'annulent
avant de se séparer pierre hérisson
confié aux représentants des maires
qu'ils souhaitent garantir la présence
de l'état au capital de la poste
il modifiera le projet doit en
conséquence le capital de la société
détenue par l'état ou par d'autres
personnes morales appartenant au secteur
public
le sénat va demander le fonctionnement
sur le changement de climat est parce
que si on pousse le raisonnement à
l'absurde on peut considérer qu'un jour
la caisse des dépôts ou d'autres
organismes publics deviennent pour
majorité en voir porter
l'idée de capital de 2 des verts ainsi
la présence de l'état et c'est un peu
les aînés deux points sur lequel il faut
qu'on mette un garde-fou et 1 victoire
de son club qui vient remplacer le rouge
clair je le signalais parce qu'on va le
défendre
pour l'instant donc l'avenir de tout un
mot qui change
et voilà l'état assuré de rester au
capital de la poste
une avancée bien maigre pour les
opposants au changement de statut
5 octobre 2009 loin des auditions la
votation citoyenne s'est poursuivie des
résultats dépasse toutes les espérances
alors nous parlons fin à près de 2,2
millions 200 mille votants 2 millions de
français ont voté 98% dit non à la
privatisation de la poste
les opposants au texte exulte dans ce
dossier la privatisation du service
public postal
il ya peut-être quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas sur d'autres dossiers on n'a pas eu
par le passé c'est le fait qu'il y ait
des usagers qui sentent a cependant
appliquer dans la mobilisation
pas un des grands partis de l'opposition
ne manque à l'appel
il flotte un air de grand soir déjà vous
êtes touche là à un impact tous les
médias sont là tout le monde est aperçu
10 passé quelque chose au milieu des
micros et des caméras nicolas galépidès
le porte parole national du mouvement
savoure la victoire
le fac s'arrête pas de tourner les
téléphones avec personne et ça remonte
sa relance à rome entre les fédérations
locales les syndicats locaux les
entreprises les villages et où la
journée on est des pâtis
mardi 6 octobre au lendemain des
résultats
le gouvernement veut réagir une réunion
se tient dans une annexe de l'assemblée
nationale ils sont présents des membres
du cabinet de christian estrosi le
ministre de l'industrie en charge du
texte et les deux rapporteurs pierre
hérisson pour le sénat et jean proriol
pour l'assemblée ont fait vous
effectivement nous le gouvernement pas
exactement
on souhaitait pouvoir avant le qu'on
attendait vraiment le front du sujet je
pense que tout le monde est au point sur
le calendrier 1 dans un mois le texte
arrive au sénat cours
le gouvernement veut préparer le terrain
sur la stratégie
ce serait vraiment le ministre allait de
votre accord et je voudrais avoir votre
sentiment là-dessus c'est vraiment qu'au
sénat alors le plus tôt possible
on rassure les syndicats l'opinion
publique surtout les grands points qui
posent problème et le point qui pose
évidemment problème c'est le risque de
privatisation où on allait à la plage du
ou
fournie lundi ce matin pourquoi vous
noté ses efforts en dix ans le capital
est détenu à 100% par les tares les cas
faisant cette affaire a ses petites
affaires avec la caisse des dépôts ça
nous regarde pas au moins c'est clair il
ya aucun doute l'étape procurer cher
hérisson va profiter de la réunion pour
évoquer la mission d'aménagement du
territoire de la poste et cette
compensation par l'état
c'est ce qu'on appelle le fonds de
péréquation le fonds de péréquation
bénéficie d'une dotation d'un refus n'en
sert hérisson voudrait que l'état mette
la main à la poche mais le ministère du
budget pourrait y être hostiles sur ce
point un désaccord va apparaître entre
le rapport très du gouvernement
thierry bécourt est l'un des deux
administrateurs du sénat chargés
d'assister le rapporteur dans son
travail il va notamment planché sur la
possibilité de financer correctement la
mission d'aménagement du territoire de
la poste
on ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui que
c'est que la mission d'aménagement du
territoire est financé à 100 % c'est
loin d'être le cas
l'un des enjeux c'est l'un des
principaux enjeux de ce projet de loi et
de et du travail du sénat dessus est ce
qu'on peut faire quelque chose pour pour
sécuriser ses financements
ça fait partie des sujets qui ne sont
pas dans le projet de loi lui même mais
qui vont scier qui vont s'y rajouter
nécessairement
les internautes
voici mes chers collègues présents et en
votre nom personnel souhaité la
bienvenue au président mercredi 7
octobre c'est au tour du président de la
poste jean-paul bailly de donner sa
position sur un texte dont il a été à
l'initiative
l'audition est ouverte à tous les
sénateurs je pense que lens et des
hommes de cette taille-là la
mutualisation qu'ils agissent de la
mutualisation de services publics
c'est le cas avec les agences postales
communales ou qu'il s'agisse de la
mutualisation des activités commerçantes
et l'assomption un jean paul bailly au
ton très professoral venu présenter son
bilan aux sénateurs je n'avais pas fait
tout ça pour lesquelles on a eu pas mal
de résistances et bien là procède on se
poserait pas la question aujourd'hui de
son de son avenir et ce développement
pour savoir comment mais jean paul
bailly va aussi devoir répondre aux
questions des sénateurs et pas seulement
ceux de l'opposition
quel gars qui apporte du goût ou
comptez-vous apporter pour le maintien
de 7,17 jura temps durera
voilà ma sélection des cinq délégués
nono cause des élus et les gens aient
mis la main sur ce point dans la mesure
où on regarde mal de manoeuvres à
l'intérieur d'un 17 points on n'a pas
d'objection à ce que est une indication
plus précise si ça tisse un peu et ça
doit rassurer je sais pas c'est pas
impossible mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit absolument nécessaire est gelée
norme aujourd'hui ce sont des normes qui
sont déjà très très précise jean paul
bailly veut garder des marges de
manoeuvre en clair continuer à
développer des partenariats et ainsi
rester compétitifs à l'échelle
européenne
aussi les autres européens d or d'autres
acteurs viennent en france il faut que
nous en serons capables d'aller dans
d'autres pays d'europe
autrement dit non pas tenir pas d'avenir
si on n'est pas un vecteur en rien dans
cette différence dans ses différents
métiers
le poste hollandaise
non seulement c'est nul si vous regardez
la qualité du service d'une paille la
satisfaction de tous par ces éléments ce
qui fonctionne bien merci
pour jean paul bailly il existe de bons
modèles à l'extérieur de nos frontières
nous sommes donc allés voir en allemagne
ce que la poste était devenu
tous
que
l'allemagne a entamé la restructuration
de sa poste dès 1996 et la privatiser
deux ans plus tard elle a divisé par
deux le nombre de ses bureaux de poste
aujourd'hui il ne reste que 13 mille la
moitié se trouve chez des commerçants
comme ici à francfort dans cette
papeterie tabac qu'est ce que vous
pensez des bureaux privés
je n'ai rien remarqué il n'y a pas de
différence avec les bureaux
traditionnels
si souvent dans les bureaux il faut
attendre longtemps alors qu'ici c'est
rapide et très dans les gros bureaux on
voit là que s'étirer jusqu'à l'arrêt de
bus prenez pas rare qu'on attend d'une
demi heure avant d'atteindre le guichet
et si vous pouvez faire toutes vos
opérations
oui tout jusqu'ici je n'ai jamais eu une
expérience négative en allemagne pas d'
agences communales comme chez nous mais
deux types de relais chez des
commerçants les gros comme celui de
francfort où l'on peut faire toutes ces
opérations à condition d'y avoir son
compte et les petits qui assure un
service minimum et la baronne la poste
chez nous dans le nord c'est chez le
fleuriste on voit le logo dans un coin
du comptoir
et puis une balance à côté de la caisse
enregistreuse
chez nous c'est ça la poste bref la
poste chez un commerçant c'est plus
d'amplitude horaire mais souvent aussi
moins de services l'objectif de la
deutsche post pour 2012 remplacer tous
ses bureaux traditionnels par des
bureaux privés chez des commerçants
en allemagne la distribution du courrier
a aussi évolué de nouveaux concurrents
notamment étrangers se sont installés
comme la tnt la poste nationale
hollandaise avec un seul objectif des
grosses entreprises gros surtout des
grosses entreprises des petites parfois
mai
parce que la tène et s'intéressent
uniquement aux volumes la tnt à cibler
le marché le plus rentable la
distribution du courrier d'entreprise
aux particuliers et pour accroître ses
marges
elle a déposé un recours contre l'accord
sur les salaires du secteur postal et
paye moins ses salariés alors le
courrier en france va-t-il connaître les
mêmes changements
retour à paris il est huit heures du
matin jean-françois entame sa tournée il
environ 300 plis la distribuer bonjour
j'ai deux plis pour les avocats la cour
nickel haddad et axel lagache voici
merci beaucoup très bonne journée au
revoir jean françois n'est ni un livre
ni un cours chimay bien salarié d'un
concurrent de la poste qui opère déjà
sur un secteur en concurrence les plis
de plus de 50 grammes
tout comme les facteurs il a accès aux
immeubles et surtout aux boîtes aux
lettres
et si les clients font appel à son
entreprise c'est que prestissimo propose
des tarifs encore plus bas que ceux de
la poste
son secret ne faire des tournées que
quand il ya du courrier à distribuer
toutes nos adresses sont dans le même
quart série on essaie que en fait les
toiles et les tournées soit très
homogène pour pas pour éviter les
grandes distances et pouvoir livrer le
plus d'exemplaires en un minimum de
temps
la poste aura elle les jours la même
tournée si la poste va tous les jours
chez tout le monde sait qu'elle est en
charge du service universel du courrier
sa principale mission de service public
grâce à son monopole sur les plis de
moins de 50 grammes
elle n'a pas de concurrent et gagne de
l'argent le service universel est
financé par ce qu'on appelle le secteur
réservé
c'est à dire le monopole résiduel des
postes nationale pour la levée le tri la
distribution des plis de moins de 50
grammes avec l'ouverture totale à la
concurrence au 1er janvier 2011 du
secteur postal
ce mode de financement va disparaître
en janvier 2011 la donne va changer car
la poste va perdre des parts de marché
mais sera toujours soumis au service
universel en d'autres termes ses
concurrents iront là où il ya beaucoup
de courrier à distribuer comme les
quartiers d'affaires mais pas au fin
fond des départements français un manque
à gagner pour la poste qu'elle évalue à
un milliard d'euros
je suis yannick jauzion le fondateur
donc de la société alternative post qui
est une société privée de distribution
de courriers adressés pour compenser le
manque à gagner de la poste le texte du
gouvernement prévoit une taxe sur le
chiffre d'affaires de ses concurrents un
plus pour la poste mais un vrai handicap
pour les nouveaux entrants
vous comprendrez qu'en tant
qu'entreprise privée on a une
interrogation très fort sur le
financement du service universel c'est à
dire qu'on parle d'un fonds de
compensation qui serait en partie abondé
par les entreprises
opérant sur le secteur postal les
dirigeants d'alternative post n'auront
plus à se poser la question
depuis le tournage de cette audition la
société a été liquidée faute
d'investisseurs solides preuves que la
concurrence postale est loin d'attirer
les capitaux
vous êtes ici dans un centre de tri
postal privé tel qu'il en existe
quelques en europe
pour denis cahier fondateur de
prestissimo rien n'est fait pour
favoriser la concurrence en france la
loi postale est une loi qui a été
proposé par l'opérateur postal lui-même
par les équipes de jean paul bert il est
évident qu'il est allé très vite au
sénat et que le lobby de la pop
fonctionne excessivement bien
or on critique souvent le privé d'avoir
des réseaux qui lui permettent
d'atteindre les objectifs capitalistique
et législatif il se trouve que dans ce
domaine on est plutôt dans la situation
inverse c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui dans
un domaine où on demande tout
contribuable français où la poste tient
tout ce qu'elle veut et où les
opérateurs alternatifs ne sont
absolument pas descendre
mardi 20 octobre le calendrier
s'accélère au sénat à dix jours de
l'examen du texte en séance
l'opposition s'organise et convoque la
presse
quels efforts pour attaquer le projet de
loi sur la poste alors l'ump n'a pas la
majorité absolue ce qui veut dire que si
les trois groupes qui sont ici présents
ont été rejoints par des sénateurs du
groupe centriste nous pourrions arriver
à ce résultat
doit-on abandonné les territoires vont
boiton abandonner les banlieues bruce
sommes pour le maintien du statut actuel
établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial
je proposerai à nicolas galépidès de
s'exprimer aujourd'hui la bataille est
au sénat on vous suit au sénat on sera
devant le sénat pendant toute la semaine
les débats
quelques étages plus haut maxime
reversals autres administrateurs qui
assistent pierre hérisson reçoit un mail
du cabinet de christian estrosi le
ministre de l'industrie
il ya eu trois enfants un des
amendements du rapporteur prévoit
d'exonérer la poste à 100 % de taxe
professionnelle afin de financer sa
mission d'aménagement du territoire
mais il n'aura pas le soutien du
gouvernement une réunion entre des
différents ministres concernés à
trancher la question
cet amendement pour les finances
publiques de 72 euros environ sur cet
amendement et nous faut le l'accord du
gouvernement pierre hérisson avait le
soutien de christian estrosi sur cet
amendement
mais le ministère du budget a mis son
veto le rapporteur va pourtant maintenir
et défendre sa position quelques heures
plus tard à l'occasion de la
présentation de son rapport devant la
commission de l'économie du sénat
les ministres concernés sont présents
christian estrosi le ministre de
l'industrie et michel mercier celui de
l'aménagement du territoire on est
devant lui baptisation primates isation
au contraire la joie après la discussion
générale sur le texte
le rapporteur présente ces amendements à
la commission des amendements votés sans
problème jusqu'à celui concernant le
financement de la mission d'aménagement
du territoire de la poste
assen concentre là maintenant venez
piscine n'a pas sur les bases
d'imposition locale ainsi que sur la
cotisation minimale de taxe
professionnelle
christian estrosi alors devoir défendre
la position du gouvernement malgré
l'avis défavorable de piston estrosi
s'il veut revenir sur cette disposition
le ministre de l'industrie devra déposer
un amendement en séance publique la
commission adopte le projet de loi ainsi
modifié il sera examiné tel quel en
séance publique
lundi 2 novembre le sénat dans son
ensemble se prépare à examiner la
réforme postale
côté majorité les messages divergent
je ne permettrai pas un gouvernement
socialiste qui dans le pire de mes
cauchemars reviendrai demain de pouvoir
privatiser puisque je vais la rendre
c'est un mot qui n'est pas français mais
que j'utilise à dessein un privatisable
la poste sera un privatisable pour
christian estrosi mais henri guaino
conseiller spécial de nicolas sarkozy
déclare lui qu'il n'y a pas de garantie
éternelle dans la rue la mobilisation
continue à deux pas du sénat nous savons
c'est la fin du service universel du
courrier la fin de la banque postale
aussi qu'est la banque de ceux qui n'ont
pas d'autres banques
et puis un vrai problème de
développement pour certains de nos
territoires
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
des projets de loi relatif à
l'entreprise publique la poste et aux
activités postales dans l'hémicycle la
discussion générale commence le début
d'un long marathon avec ce projet de loi
sur la poste commence l'examen d'un
texte aussi politisés que médiatisée
le projet du gouvernement a donc pour
ambition tout simplement de donner sa
chance à la poste et il n'y aura aucun
euro de capitaux privés à la poste le
gouvernement veut rapidement faire
sauter le verrou
pour constituer leur statut actuel
pour pouvoir ouvrir le capital de la
poste par une loi ultérieure on ne sauve
pas la service public en le modifiant le
propre d'un service public est de savoir
s'adapter quand quelques minutes nous
serons mardi et ce jour là comme
beaucoup d'autres 100000 facteurs
distribuent rang courrier dans
pratiquement 30 millions de boîtes aux
lettres mais ils apporteront aussi une
présence humaine d'un sourire un regard
à des gens qui en manquent
et souvent dans des lieux de solitude de
profondes
mardi 3 novembre forte du succès de la
votation citoyenne la gauche dépose une
motion demandant au gouvernement
d'organiser un véritable référendum sur
le sujet une motion référendaire
le gouvernement serait bien inspiré de
demander l'avis des français sur sur
cette question essentielle parce que
c'est la poste mais c'est dans le fort
la question du service public en général
la presse est au rendez vous une étrange
procession se forme alors pour remettre
la motion en mains propres au président
du sénat messieurs je suis attendu le
président très même un peu gros bras
ancien et un peu d'histoire puisque on
aurait pu faire la porte ouverte à jean
laisser penser qu'il fallait le remettre
avant la séance donc voilà je vous
remets la liste des sénateurs avant tout
le monde
là
l'opposition ne s'arrête pas là elle a
décidé de marquer le coup dans
l'hémicycle mais voilà conclure allez-y
non pas quelques bel et bien mais encore
30 secondes mais d'autres motions visant
à rejeter le texte vont être examinés
tout au long de ce deuxième jour des
motions sur lesquels des sénateurs
doivent se prononcer or les sénateurs de
gauche ultra mobilisés sont majoritaires
dans l'hémicycle
il y a ce soir 115 parlementaires en
séance je tente deux aides dans
l'expérience à 11h30 j'ai rarement vu ça
les votes se font par scrutin public et
non plus à main levée la droite peut
ainsi de voter pour les absents mais la
procédure ralenti les débats
mercredi 4 novembre c'est au tour de la
motion référendaire d'être examiné le
projet de loi s'enlise
ce matin on va passer je crois un peu
plus de quatre heures à débattre de
cette demande de référendum
et je vous rappelle que on est au
troisième jour de discussions et on n'a
toujours pas entamé l'article ou un
sénateur de la majorité qui se sont
moqués des conditions d'organisation de
la votation citoyenne du 3 octobre
aujourd'hui vous avez l'occasion de
rectifier le tir quand on n'a pas de
projet quand on n'a pas d'idée on
propose un référendum je vous propose en
refusant cette motion référendaire
et bien c'est de libérer la gauche
responsable de la surenchère trotskiste
de sud et donne une extrême gauche
parfaitement irresponsable
pour l'adoption 152 voix contre 183
la motion référendaire sera rejetée sans
surprise au 3e jour les sénateurs à bord
enfin l'article 1
le changement de statut de la poste je
vais me permettre de faire référence
pour terminer au rapport d'information
numéro 42 rédigé en 1997 1998 par gérard
larcher où il estime que la society
dation de cette entreprise n'apparaît
pas indispensable je pense qu'il a
entièrement raison
le changement de statut est la meilleure
solution pour que la poste puisse
bénéficier d'un apport de fonds propres
sans contestation de la part de la
commission européenne
ici depuis des années l'état avait donné
ce qu'ils devaient pour les missions
assurées jamais vous n'auriez on aurait
besoin à l'heure actuelle de faire cet
appel de fonds supplémentaires le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
jeudi 5 novembre le sénat transforme la
poste en société anonyme a adopté après
en coulisses une polémique est en train
de naître entre christian estrosi et
certains sénateurs socialistes
le ministre se révèle être un
utilisateur assidu du site twitter
depuis l'hémicycle
il y écrit des commentaires en des
termes peu diplomatiques
je commence le bêtisier bourquin ps
efficacité du service publique
mais cette efficacité pas au détriment
du service public
ce sosie je suis un autodidacte comme
vous service public c'est assez sait pas
qu eux
quand on parle de l'identité nationale
l'orthographe fait partie de l'identité
nationale
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
toutes mes forces
en avoir fait une grande promotion parce
que ça va permettre à beaucoup plus de
gens de se brancher sur twitter
l'incident est révélateur de la guerre
des nerfs qui oppose les deux parties
après quatre jours de débats et bien que
le sénat siègent tous les soirs jusqu'à
minuit 500 amendements restent à
examiner les débats seront prolonger
tout le week-end
on va faire un à six levées mes chers
collègues parce que c'est serré alors
qui est pour et qui est contre
vendredi matin la surprise générale des
amendements socialistes sont adoptés il
est adopté
la majorité n'a pas demandé de scrutin
public et s'est laissé piéger par la
forte mobilisation des sénateurs de
gauche
un des amendements prévoient de faire de
la poste un groupe entièrement public
dans les couloirs du sénat des hauts
cadres de la poste s'activent la
précision leur pose visiblement problème
tout comme au gouvernement des
amendements ont été votés contre la
ville du gouvernement reste du temps
pour montrer un petit peu là non utilité
de ces un moment sur leur lancée les
socialistes tentent de faire adopter
d'autres modifications en mettant un
frein à la politique de partenariat de
la poste
chers collègues je vous demande je vous
demandais je vous incite vraiment à être
très vigilants sur ces articles ne
pensez pas que les dix sept mille points
de contact est une gare sont une
garantie
pas du tout si vous n'avez pas les
critères de ces points de contact fait à
17000 relais pmu et on ne m'en parle
maintenant 17 mai le point de contact
j'espère qu'il s'agit pas de mettre les
points de contact de la poste au pmu
dont moi je tiens à ce qu'il y ait un
bar où on va m'entendre justement ce qui
se passe dans le village qu'on aura
quand ce qui se passe et l on va aller
retirer leurs commandes et les trucs du
métier
le courrier trésor public la
correspondance à ses employeurs on va
justement vous raconte des histoires là
l'humour ne suffira pas à convaincre la
majorité
pour le rapporteur les différentes
catégories de points de contacts n'ont
pas à figurer dans la loi
pour bonne soirée
et
la séance est reprise samedi 7 novembre
le sénat se penche sur la mission
d'aménagement du territoire de la poste
c'est sur ce point que le gouvernement
avait été battu en commission je
remercie monsieur le ministre et fermin
et soupçonnait des discussions même au
plus haut niveau pour garantir cette
compensation
mais je crois que dans cette dent dans
cet amendement du gouvernement ainsi
modifiées nous obtenons toutes les
garanties et des garanties qui ont être
révisés annuellement en fonction du coût
de ce service public
un compromis a depuis été trouvé le coût
sera bien compensé par l'état mais après
évaluation par un organisme indépendant
et non plus sur la base des chiffres
donnés par la poste une manière de
connaître le coût réel de la présence
postale qui n'a cessé de baisser
avec la hausse des partenariats mais
l'article de terre qui assure le
financement est fondamentale
vous pouvez pas laisser des fonds sans
prévoir les méthodes de financement il
faut être cohérent et essayer de sauver
ce qui est possible de sauver ce qui est
important c'est d'assurer un financement
je le répète est intégral et pérenne de
la mission de présence postale
donc nous accepterons cet amendement le
scrutin est ouvert
la gauche se rallie à l'initiative la
mesure est largement voté par le sénat
pour l'adoption 315 contre 23
le sénat a adopté
dimanche 6 novembre au 7e jour le rythme
s'accélère l'issue des débats et en vue
depuis le début de la semaine certaines
personnes suivent de très près les
discussions
juste au dessus des sénateurs en
tribunes publiques des cadres dirigeants
de la poste mais aussi le syndicaliste
nicolas galépidès il est venu en soutien
logistique à l'invitation de
l'opposition pas surpris par la tournure
qu'ont pris les débats il se montre
toutefois critiques vis-à-vis du
financement de la présence postale sur
trois or le modèle économique actuel de
la poste permet de compenser ces choses
là poste depuis qu'elle existe en tant
qu'établissement public depuis 90 la
moyenne de ses gains sur une vingtaine
d'années on va dire ça comme ça
c'est à peu près 150 millions d'euros
par an c'est quand même très correct
tout ce qui n'est entreprise publique
peut payer à la collectivité
les cadres dirigeants de la poste se
sont préoccupés par les amendements
socialistes adopté deux jours plus tôt
notamment celui qui vise à garantir le
capital public de la poste
certains sont contradictoires avec le
reste du texte sur la notion de groupe
exclusivement public et pour les autres
qui viennent compléter les choses
ont-elles appartenant au gouvernement d'
savoir s'il souhaite revenir dessus
entièrement public une contrainte pour
la poste qui serait alors à l'avenir
dépendante des deniers de l'état
monsieur le ministre il compte sur le
gouvernement pour revenir dessus et
c'est justement ce qu'il va faire à la
toute fin des débats en demandant comme
il en a le droit
une seconde délibération le gouvernement
vos propos christian estrosi propose de
retirer du texte d'expression
entièrement public la majorité cette
fois rendez vous je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur cet
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
dans le cas d'une seconde délibération
pour l'adoption 183 contre 152 le sénat
a donc adopté ce soir on nous apprend
que dans le fond si nous avons réussi à
faire passer
deux ou trois amendements et bien tout
cela tenait de l'entourloupe
nous ne le croyons pas cava 22 heures
avant le vote final sur ce texte afin
pour le moins au sénat vous arriveriez
avec un amendement qui contredit ce que
vous nous avez vous avez tenté de nous
faire croire pendant huit jours que la
poste était un privatisable il va être
procédé au retrait d'un public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 de
notre règlement chapelle mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires bien vouloir
venir à leur emplacement pour un
bulletin blanc contre un bulletin bleu
rouge
ceux qui souhaitent obtenir lundi 9
novembre le sénat vote sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi
pour l'adoption 183 contre 152 le sénat
a donc adopté après 68 heures de débat
le texte est adopté tel que le
souhaitait la majorité
oh
à